Jeff Julie well we have three little
boys but they're trapped in cat bodies
our babies are cuts there my whole life
besides my husband and my business I
speak a feline coming in Jeff I'm
ringing in his orders okay to be
prepared
Timmy if chef Frances just another
customer I mean as long as he likes my
food we're gonna get along just fine
walking out I think he's gonna love the
salad it's a girl lettuce I mean can't
go wrong grilled salad
in his grill he's still amazed I'm short
I've never thought about it but it's
true like wait why are we grilling
lettuce
[Music]
sorry for interrupting just three
seconds but this is the first for me a
grilled Caesar salad de nervous bench
deep grilled the letter can you just
show a hand if anyone else has ever had
a grilled Caesar salad before anybody
here ladies no sorry
oh jeez I always get nervous when a chef
says with a butter lettuce when you've
got the butter the next on you can never
clean the letters properly and
unfortunately it's not very nice inside
dry chicken the salad looks hideous
Jesus thanks them why because I know
what's coming next I will say this for
me is a new journey in life because I've
always been a shoe salesman seriously
not a man shoes oh sorry oh that's gonna
say Lisa right it's gonna I don't really
how would you write the food the only
issue is that I cannot eat Italian food
because I'm gluten intolerance so why
are you here I'm a combination of
everything I'm like mirage' /r so you'll
manager everything else
[ __ ] / see the manager of galleries
Hilary general manager / shoe salesman
you Bernard I'm also he hopes you're
hurt you know the first person I do it
on Wow
Rita yes serious general manager he is
the bus boy you're not the general
manager I just assumed their own are you
soon role to yourself justice they don't
realize sweating you're sweaty
yes I'm [ __ ] myself he's the he's
the bus man and I fired him and let me
explain to you audience
you finally fired a wooden falling for
because he told me that he was more
important than me and he got me on a bad
day and it got upset and I fired him
sirs so you know what he did he got an
umbrella cause it was raining that day
you got an umbrella yes and he would
walk by and look in like if Emma said
poppy I'm like this poor guy so I I took
him back I took him back and I would
just let him tell him sorry manager for
everything that Pat does right he does
five things wrong go now go oh god he's
so [ __ ] crazy that it's like is it
really worth even having a meow he's but
it is I love Pat that's good enough
oh look please put that down that looks
oh is that my rack oh this is just so we
can show you guys the Cape they come
from Cleveland and it's like a
procession of human food cake warm pasta
gonna throw some flowers out any more
possible as we do when people are dead
you should be do you should have that
tournament
you carry the further procession there
we go
[Laughter]
what antibody it'll put carrots on it a
puff pastry why would you do that
this would be your scallop on croute
thanks a night
[Music]
these are the local counts micro carrots
I'm microcars
ya from local farms you know things you
let it grow vit well I don't think
they're there to be really eaten there
for garnish oh that's a garnish oh I'll
stay add some color okay
but I'd like to explain what we're
spending on micro carrots yeah we go
through this often whatever you want to
do your you are here right as our guest
trying to give those back to Joe I don't
personally want them myself well you can
take them back to the kitchen huh no I
present in one them thank you my me
I have staff here that'll take care of
that you don't hand me raw food in my
dining room we don't need them to bust
our balls over if there's little petite
carrots that go there don't sing carrots
go to the White House so same carrots go
to the five seasons they go global
tell Michael jump you need my setup soap
no that's fine but you see Santa's that
look honestly
how [ __ ] depressing is that why are
you serious kid job please come look at
the poor child please
he got his bit now the map of America
son of these cursed California with a
little dark spot is from the central
Midwest and we have Seattle we're here
Pittsburgh
[Music]
[ __ ] flying Chanel did you taste it
if you got to stand out that mean it's
too hard
I'm not to pull so I see you had a
chance to taste the pork chop and now
what did you think you're drunk like a
mouthful of sand it's drier than mr.
Howard desert right even the Flies no
longer interested okay is there anything
else you wanted me to get for you or a
wheel for that bike out there that way I
can get the [ __ ] out of it what's this
about ready please
it's at five cheese stuffed ravioli then
the five cheese's are I'm not sure well
it's a premade ravioli
so no how might those are not homemade
if we don't even make them here be nice
to know what's inside them I'll find out
enough we thank you I need to find out
what cheeses are in the ravioli or
cheese yeah what kind of cheese in the
bread Romeo
read the box it's a retired cheese it's
a retired cheese I like um no horrible
or something deep fried frozen that's
leaving taste like cheese you got a
whole weight and you got American Rana
and uh skim cheese yeah okay perfect
guys thank you yes ya know cuz transy I
checked on the cheese's for you uh
mascarpone mascarpone ricotta ricotta
also American gharana something called
our cheese way in the hole true blend
where the [ __ ] is that feloniously I'd I
have no idea where that's from
oh and a skim cheese skimmed cheese in a
fried ravioli what does that mean it's
fat-free cheese dipped in fact it's in
fact about $10 tip yeah yeah why not did
you think the girls deserve some tips
tonight
no take it hourly sir the tipping left
the young lady server the owner takes
the tips then oh [ __ ] we do
hello everybody welcome to the Greek of
the harbor my name is eros we're gonna
perform a little dancing for you right
now so please enjoy the show there's
more dances to come
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's not collecting your long break
dancing and dancing and believe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now I get what he's passionate about
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
despite Eris pleasing some of the diners
with his dancing
they continue to be far from pleased
with the food chips are still slimy
where's Mike what is this smell that
just smell inside that inside what's
wrong about it a little bit I'm not
eating no it's smell yes it's what it's
good you're sick
Mike you're sick I'm very worried about
Mikey because it should be obvious when
something's not cooked properly there's
no way that you can say oh well they
were just complainers it's real eres you
need to know what's going on here as
well as far as your father's concerned
it's good there's nothing wrong with it
Estrella so he's not even the chef and
he knows it's dry come on Mike you stood
there and watch that [ __ ] come out it's
an embarrassment to Catalonia